let's talk about flying and how it just
became an even
bigger headache it's the social
distancing
the masks the extra documents
and the hours of waiting it's a
nightmare for the industry too
i can't see international travel
returning to anywhere near
normality for a very long time so is it
safe to fly again
who's going to pay for it and how's the
pandemic changed
how we fly forever
[Music]
before the pandemic hit the global
travel industry
was booming many saw it as a golden age
of commercial air travel
over the last 10 years growth in the
airline industry had skipped along
nicely
more than 5 a year
a bunch of low-cost carriers joined the
game flying more people to more places
starting from 130
it was a heyday they had never had days
like that
however 2020 came
it was the worst kind of turbulence
imagine
seven and a half million flights
cancelled between january and july
people demanding their money back and no
one booking thousands of planes grounded
and fighting for parking spots now to
put the losses in perspective
before kova 19 the industry was looking
forward to more than 870 billion dollars
in revenue for 2020.
now it's more like 419 billion
half of what the airlines took in last
year and next year
doesn't look much better air traffic
isn't expected to get anywhere near
those pre-coveted days before
2023 and maybe not even before 2025.
it's so bad that many airlines are
turning to governments for multi-billion
dollar bailouts
thai airways lufthansa latam they nearly
went bust
hong kong's cathay pacific received a 5
billion dollar bailout
emirates etihad and qatar airways
recently announced job losses
and pay cuts of up to 50 and those were
just the airlines
plane manufacturers are cutting jobs too
boeing is aiming for 16 thousand
airbus already cut fifteen thousand
all three airline major airlines here in
the united states have said they're
going to come out of this and they're
gonna come out of this
smaller so that's going to lead to fewer
jobs
in the industry it's not going to be
like it was
at its peak in 2019 and that's because
people just aren't expected to fly as
much as they used to
a lot of people have lost their jobs
some are just afraid
sure some governments are lifting border
restrictions and travel is starting to
pick up again
but not in the same way not even close
it means the way we fly
will have to change we've had to adapt
before
take 911 for instance after the plane
hijackings
airport screenings were tightened and
locked cockpits became the industry
standard
the passenger's attempt to hide a
detonator in his shoe led to more
travelers having to take off theirs
a few years later the uk uncovered a
terror plot that involved
smuggling explosive liquids it's one
reason why the amount of liquids we can
take on board
is still restricted and now the security
threat
is a virus it's a new kind of threat
that's making air travel
weirder than ever it was swarming with
staff who were there to assist the
passengers on my flight
getting off the plane going through all
the checks again making sure that you
had all your paperwork
all of these people were in protective
gear basically hazmat
suits and here's more of what you can
expect
obligatory masks temperature scans
longer check-in and security cues
and when you board the plane you might
even get handed a face shield
or hand sanitizer crew are likely to
wear nearly full protective gear
not to mention the fact that the entire
aircraft will have been disinfected
from the moment you walk into the
airplane you're touching an enormous
number of things you're
adjusting your airflow you're putting on
your seat belt you're playing with the
inflight
entertainment system you're touching
your tray and whatnot
we want to make sure that all of those
are properly sanitized and sanitized
over and over on a regular basis the
industry is
trying to build public confidence to
attract more passengers
but it still has to convince all those
people who believe that planes are just
giant germ incubators so we asked boeing
about that
there's an urban myth that air on an
airplane is
simply recirculated and it's the same
air and you're catching the same germs
that the other guy just
emitted that's not true here's why
air inside the cabin gets sucked through
what are called hepa filters
according to boeing they remove 99.9
of all bacteria and viruses including
ones the size of the coronavirus
the filtered air is then mixed with
fresh air from outside and recirculates
back into the cabin
and the air flows from the ceiling to
the floor meaning germs are harder to
spread from passenger to passenger
it's actually safer to be in the cabin
of an airplane than it is say in a
crowded restaurant
or on public transportation or perhaps
even in your car
so that's where things stand now but
more changes could be on the way
the un's aviation body is suggesting
things like pre-packaged food
taking the bare minimum on board stuff
you can fit under your seat
and even restricting which bathrooms we
can use
and then there's the seating social
distancing should really apply here too
if possible but some safety
recommendations
just cost the industry too much money
and they're unsustainable
airlines like westjet and air canada are
already filling those middle seats
they can't afford not to others will
pass those costs onto consumers
social distancing on a plane costs money
so it's highly likely that the
passengers will start to
bear the brunt of the costs for keeping
flights safe and clean
right now though some airlines are
discounting tickets to attract customers
one website has reported price cuts of
up to 40 percent for european package
holidays
but few expect those low prices to last
and maybe that's a good thing look at
barcelona
before the pandemic it was getting
swamped by tourists
and locals were pushing back
even the most remote places have been
overrun
mount everest even had a traffic jam you
have
a huge garbage problem you have a huge
crowding problem and you have a problem
of
the destruction of the environment and
the culture that's just what happens
when you have hyperterrorism
especially when tickets are cheap we
have gotten
so used to what in the industry is
called drive
by tourism fly somewhere welcome to
berries
stay at an inexpensive hotel get on
buses
go see the eiffel tower go see
the pyramids outside of cairo come back
a lot of airlines are now focused on
restarting flights to only their most
profitable destinations canadian
airlines for instance scrapped
30 domestic routes and that means fewer
options and more expensive tickets
flying just became that much more
exclusive i felt fortunate to get on
board that flight a lot of people
around the world are trying to get back
to various countries aren't they where
they live
where they work where their family
members may be
and not many are being able to achieve
that
i think you're going to appreciate it's
going to require you
to not be to live about just getting on
an airplane
the airline industry has come in for a
hard landing
it's going to have to adapt to survive
and thus
well we're just gonna have to adapt
[Music]
if you're new to our show i'm glad you
found us start here is an online series
that unpicks the news
we've got new episodes every week
explaining the big stories like the war
in yemen
or what israel is doing in the west bank
make sure to like follow and subscribe
to al jazeera wherever you're watching
this video
and i'll see you next week